hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember so you don't have to this is
one of those movies that doesn't even
need an introduction I don't need to say
anything about all you got to do is look
at the fucking cover if you didn't laugh
your ass off looking at this thang
obvious same asylums they've been
looking for you this is distant Roxanne
[Music]
from the brilliant director of the
neverending story to here's a story
about a dog in a dolphin who beat gran
one another how can you even say that
with a straight face a dog and a dog
well your new room for a pony in a
chitlin to join the fun and to make sure
there's absolutely nothing redeemable
about this movie
they add it's the Guzman what it's
sherry on top so for all of those who
always want to see flipper meet classy
fucking out for the rest of us this is
Gusev Roxanne so we open up with the
pretty sunrise over the ocean yeah this
movie stock that's all fuzzy scroll you
even see the poster
[Music]
Wow this movie wastes no time sucking
doesn't it simply jump right into the
heart of what's going to be absolutely
horrible about this press so dog wipe
dolphin how touching and creepy but
surely there's some human characters to
balance out the insipidus of the story
hey I said human that's Steve Guttenberg
doc doctor
let's welcome dinner breakfast I know
that you've been up all night again huh
sorry I just that I've been working on
this melody and what did he marry this
kid or something he's cooking for him
he's trying to be what's possible for
who do only gusty goober he'll be so
much work
so what's in this burrito refried beans
onions jalapenos peanut butter
mozzarella cheese pineapple chunks good
boy Oh glad you finished yours I'll go
get you another one so this is Terry and
his son Jordan they have a summer home
in Key West and live right next door to
a marine biologist named Mary Beth and
her two daughters Judith and Nora the
only downside is that their dog Zeus
seems to keep getting into trouble over
a Mary Beth's out I'm so sorry I'm sorry
Barnett Mary Beth all right Beth
excuse me my force wide-eyed whimsical
that seems to follow me to have a
performance meter you cutie you know oh
wait you forgot to make that charming or
clever
so while Gutenberg agrees to keep a
closer eye on Zeus he went singles for
his next commercial that's right he
writes jingles for commercials who knew
that could pay for a summer home in Key
West next you'll be telling me the
internet reviewers can make a living
making fun of movies good old goober
keeping a close eye on their dog to make
sure that no danger may befall him idiot
[Music]
stop insulting I'm a dog who $24 don't
ask me why I just want a dolphin go bad
so we see that Marybeth is trying to get
a grand for her research on a dolphin
named Roxanne the only problem is she
has competition with I didn't know I
ever had one ah change your mind
I can't respect you trying to kill
Brendan Fraser but you read Mary Beth
alone
so our species confused canine follows
Mary Beth through extreme measures to
get on board and see Roxanne by the
sequel right to talk
so working scientists discovered that
Zeus is on board and beside there's
nothing they can do but continue on to
Roxanne just fight back you'll deal with
military love a big old trick so they
finally come across the chipper rock van
I just want to get a closer look at her
[Music]
okay this is getting scary
Zeus obviously has a sick obsession that
is probably not very healthy don't
believe me then check out is poor
so when it looks like their research is
over they pull up the anchor and take
off yes yes yes
that was awesome let's say that again oh
[Applause]
my god what that employees time thank
you for that movie I really needed that
okay continue to suck now
[Music]
can I just see that a dolphin just punch
the shark in the fucking mouth are you
fucking serious girl or who knew a
dolphin punch was so deadly let me get
those things a Pearl Harbor they would
have saved the day oh we shall solve the
whole bycatch is often here the dolphin
budge in knocks out sharks dolphin punch
oh my gosh come here
[Music]
I have to document how stupid this
moment is so it turns out not only to
the dog and the dolphin like each other
but they can also communicate with each
other so Marybeth think she's a shoo-in
now for the grant but first she has to
ask Guttenberg son Jordan if it's all
right to keep using it Wow did you do
all these yes
that one's going to be the compass from
my dad's after squat so let me get this
straight we have a dog who has a strange
obsession with a dolphin and a boy who
has a strange obsession with a dog this
is like a psychiatric case from Doctor
Dolittle it might be really interesting
to get the two together soon Roxanna and
just seeing how things were to go from
there the Sun agrees that they all go
out to sea to watch the to communicate
[Music]
you're doing out there with that dog
I'll tell you what you she's trying to
steal my grunt well it's just not going
to happen
no sir I was just establishing that I
was the villain of this picture did you
get that did you get that I was the
villain of this picture because I am
because I don't want to get her brat no
sir Billy so we think Mary Beth's
daughter get in trouble for trespassing
but luckily rebel without a career drops
by to talk with the cop he seems to
convince the cops to let the girls go as
he quite illegally drives all of them
away on his motorcycle this Accord leads
to more quirky awkward talk from our
romantically she's asking you out right
hey what but but hey what bad montage
off the port bow so while Jordan takes a
picture of my nightmare for the next two
weeks
Mary Benson Guttenberg seemed to hit it
off quite well by the movie Sam for the
rest of us it's like watching a bad
episode of blind date this son this
Claude guy GCU
[Music]
everyday he's a head honcho at the
Institute I should be as assistant but
we had a parting of the way would it be
tactless to ask over what Derrick party
oh I apologize nevermind I didn't I had
Johnson selector Guttenberg and Mary
Beth make it to first base we see our
villain trying to sneak a peek at her
research what is he doing with his lip
what he turned a Beeker from the Muppets
for a second so he escapes and sees that
he can drive dolphin communication with
other animals
but sadly none of them has the sick
disturbing love that do seem our fans
seem to feel for each other hey speaking
of which we haven't seen much of them
help I mean we're at the our mark here
we've only had two scenes with the
animals together
one was only ten minutes in the other
was under five it should have just
called this movie Guttenberg and Mary
Steenburgen look-alike that would have
been more accurate Oh just meant it
killed thousands of dolphins every year
come on let's lead Roxanna yeah we don't
want to get caught in those Nets no a
fucking shark comes along that's okay
but if she gets caught mozo's next so so
like you're a few more days our
lovebirds decide Goodin birch and move
in with Mary Beth but this leads to some
issue that he starts thinking about his
deceased wife are you doing this for we
do this for us we do this for the
Rothman foundation are we doing it for
the kids
No
I think you missed a line here's about
to say I'm having second thoughts she
supposed to say why and then you know
okay you don't know
so because Guttenberg doesn't know he
could like he wants to move away and
take Zeus in Jordan with him
this leads to the most groundbreaking
question that this movie no no any movie
has ever asked in the history of math if
a dog and a dolphin can get along why
can't our mom and dad
it was so simple all this time dissolved
in the solvent we go to the dog
development yes quickly getting
everybody in the world together it's a
dog and it's also get a lot
[Music]
ah
the dog in the dog I don't get
so after Gutenberg Jordan and Zeus
finally move away we see this who spends
most of his time watching Oh God
really really where we missus what he
spends his free kind of doing did he
really learn how to change the channels
until he found something with dolphins
in it or is he just watching the OL
ironic Channel can you even get it why
couldn't they just leave the dog this
makes no sense
a gigantic scientific breakthrough
totally destroyed because Gutenberg
doesn't know he's looking for doo doo
doo this is a little more proactive as
he decides to see there was beloved
dolphins or not goodbye
so Zeus literally travels all the way
back to Mary Beth so that he can be with
his beloved Roxanne again
[Music]
so the kids talk to each other and
divide the trick to keep Gutenberg and
Mary Beth talking to each other again
but unfortunately our villain finds the
dog in Texas hoping to use them to find
and communicate with Roxanne right Elmo
mr. nice guy what was their plan to
sabotage the competition but I like you
doesn't want that
now that would be awesome now Roxanne is
an ass
no dr. Carver yours we quit are you
seriously telling me that kidnapping is
dog to entrap a dolphin is your idea of
unethical so Gutenberg and Jordan fly
back to Key West at the turns out his
son has some very choice words about the
situation this is a extremely extreme
job that is he's also in love an extreme
emotion why don't you try it sometime
dad Oh Gutenberg nothing kids take
pictures of the dog dressed as a frog
what so as the bad guy tries to lure
Roxana and we find that Roxanne is one
step ahead of their day
Wow so people and sharks pose no threat
to this dolphin but if she comes across
the two minutes whew
and speaking of idiots who get caught in
two minutes look Mary Beth is immediate
getting caught in the Canada yeah
apparently nets are dangerous to
dolphins and really stupid marine
biologist you know what it's still worth
it
I look tuna too much it's where the feud
is dolphins a marine biologist to get my
tuna if they're so smart why didn't they
seek I'm not coming to begin with pasta
bastards I want my tuna so it may be one
of the lamest ways to fix the situation
damn if I had installed that screen door
like I originally wanted none of this
would have happened so seeing how
there's no friggin scuba gear that she
brought with her if that's the Roxanne
to find her and relaying the message
that she's in trouble oh I think he's
trying to tell us something
Wow - people are amazing before it's
with blender Oh ninjas from another
planet head full in all the earth course
[Music]
very business trip right below is an
eternity method get a better sense I
suppose in this unit why doesn't see her
I think she wants you to follow
yeah I think she also said bring an
oxygen tank
dumbass oh hold on I can't do
daughter-in-law because I didn't bring
an oxygen tank
whoa gotta go up again you know maybe I
could save precious time if I just put
on one of those oxygen tanks or maybe
even brought one down for you to breathe
through problem what do I know I'm Steve
Guttenberg so he finally get her out of
the sub at the police drop by to see
wall you haven't read the bad guy you
know met well in all my years I would
have gotten away with if it wasn't for
the besties oh and that mangy dog oh and
a dolphin this happened when we have it
so of course Guttenberg and Mary Beth
decide to get back together and finally
tie the knot right sorry they told me to
bring this down here right away ah
the postman just like the old saying
goes or rain nor snow nor sleet nor your
wedding oh well isn't this magical I
suppose only one other thing could
possibly top off this day of whimsical
delight
Oh cards how else could this movie
possibly end because there are rainbow
sprinkles in syrup and unicorn parts
that aren't it's a piousness fucking
movie this film a shit planet since we
don't think much of the dog and dolphin
together the romance is pretty bland and
none of it seems to have any surprises
it's just a sleep film with an unusually
safe premise if not a totally insane
press on top of that if dude the Roxanne
did have a relationship together what
what the kids look like not on them I'm
gonna tell your credit guy remember so
you don't have to
[Music]
if a dog and a dolphin can get along why
can't our now and exact
okay okay since you've been so patient
[Music]